okay let's say he gives me some energy
whatever
okay so this is not a yin yang
reconciliation
see i'm trying to push back on what's
pushing on me
it's a fear response okay
uh so he goes and this is your response
too
he's going
so if you let's look at what what i did
there
okay so he has uh i don't know what you
did
okay so there's a pressure and there's a
pressure
so i don't want to push here i don't
want to stop here
i don't want to push here you see so
i let it go around
so if you watch we'll watch one hand at
a time
okay uh i just let it go past me
and you watch the other one it's i'm
gonna move it out
because this mask is coming this way and
then i'll catch it
and you have the same detriment to
reconciling and young
is your fear okay so
as we're doing this technique you're
gonna already test you see
i'm already tense because i'm
anticipating the pain
okay and now i try to overpower the pain
so i resist the technique
but this thing is way stronger than me
okay this is gonna hurt
got it instead i cast myself with the
same acceptance
uh he moves my arms same acceptance you
see
in the same way i offer my hand for him
to grab
not
okay i give him my hand i give him my
highlight i give him my hand
i don't feel anything okay no
anticipation
give it to him all right now let's look
at his
energy that he's doing here he's gonna
bring his my fingers up okay
and he's gonna keep my hand from turning
you see don't don't let it turn i'm
gonna try to see that okay
and then this one is not letting me go
out nor in
and then it's gonna go down okay so
if i try to go out that's resisting if i
try to go
in that's resisting if i try to unturn
my hand god is resisting but if i
if you look at why that all happens
is same why the other one happened
your feet are how you deal with the yin
and yang reconciliation okay
so if we watch or
here like this my feet
move out of the way
that's how i take off the pressure okay
so i'm gonna go he has my
arm and once i feel him start moving i
move my body to take the pressure off
it's the same physical puzzle here comes
energy it's young in nature
reconcile it with yin okay
in the same way when he when he push
and he feels nothing
he should feel nothing too okay so he
felt my initial penetration
and then he's gonna feel boy
not tension not anticipation
not rejection okay so in
release
pull release
it's not here okay that's all i got
no okay he decides he's not yet
i'm practicing the inside of the of the
nage uk dynamic
so no you see just making this
okay remember you're not doing it for
the same reasons you do big man like he
does
you're afraid okay go this version is
low low right here technique is on don't
don't bring it up it's not going on
so he has to do all that releasing
in an instant without losing his center
his center uh computer
and feel it and protect it so low
okay